all right here's another newcomer that
I've heard a lot of people like a lot of
people have been enjoying playing with
King K rool so I think I'm gonna give
him a shot here Kincaid rule of course
from the donkey kong series and i love
looking at this too
they each classic character or each
character has kind of like a path so you
see down there right now for the duck
hunt dog it says duck hunt route and
then the theme so to speak his dog duck
zapper dog duck is a bird for like King
K rool super heavyweight class see what
that's like now the scene is awesome I
heard ya lucina's plays a lot like Marth
and I enjoy playing with her too I have
cleared classic with Lucina yes she I've
never played a single fiery mobile game
I'm sad to say so I don't know like
which games each character's from and
Martha Noi are the first two I know
because they were in smash brothers
melee and they are both back ok so be
whoa whoa that's justice be attack right
there shoots out that forward B throws
out his crown
that's his - attack he just throws his
belly at him I love it alright let's try
to see down B was them that might be a
pari of some sort see how he turned
green there he like grabs his stomach
and turns green interesting gonna keep
keep experimenting with that one see if
I can hit somebody time it to when
they're hitting me and I still have
something in my eye I think it's just an
eyelash but so clearly here we're gonna
be fighting all heavy characters it
looks like
all right forward B throws the crown the
- there's his up smash that's down smash
right there
forward smashes the one where he pulls
out the boxing glove that's down an a
just as down tilt forward tilt up tilt
[Music]
and there's this back tilt and then
forward tilt goes kind of like the kick
there alright
and I'm anxious to find out about that
downbeat
it's gotta be a Perry right king role is
best boss with best music oh man he's
he's definitely had some interesting
appearances over the years King Dedede
super heavyweight this is interesting
fighting all the heavy characters
alright let's try in time this messed it
up
should probably do it on an earlier
fight so they don't cuz the harder it
gets the harder it's gonna be for me to
land one of those Perry's alright we got
two Pokemon out there right now I think
this one heals you right her no it puts
in asleep maybe I don't know what is she
doing I don't know what Pokemon anymore
I stop pet playing Pokemon after like
gin too so I don't even know Holly's
Pokemon anymore oh man now somebody's
gonna hop in chat say well this was
actually from gin - I feel pretty dumb
then what it wouldn't shock me though
alright come on come and hit me
see what what is what is hitting me
that a fake one no it's not he dodged it
but he didn't dodge that now did he no
he didn't
dang we only gained point four for that
one I knew I let that fight drag out cuz
I was trying to parry
oh that's a pretty cool upbeat he's got
a lot of a lot of more mobility than you
would expect for a character like him oh
wait that was interesting what was that
like I kept holding beat after I fired
that little gun dude Ridley is not
playing around oh my gosh I'm trying to
grab you hey I lost my crown dude he is
messing me up
oh my gosh dude Ridley relax bro relax
he's gonna get that Smash Ball or he's
just gonna ko me anyway
Chris I caught a Pokemon Pokemon go that
was a nose
oh man that's interesting it's a
interesting idea for Pokemon I guess
there we go there we go we got him with
a final smash at least it's see a cool
ending hopefully Wow
very nice I feel like a lot of the final
smash is this time around it depends on
you like hitting them with an initial
like - I've seen several like that now
[Applause]
you still got to find out about that
down B move so Ganondorf is super
heavyweight as well all right oh yeah
let me try and do that thing again with
the gun okay so there I fire it and then
see how it like sucks it back up
actually I'm not really sure what the
purpose that is I guess fits close by
you suck it back up can you actually I
wonder if you can actually pull them
closer to you oh he just sucks up and
fires it again
dang dude
[Music]
oh I tried to parry that it was so
telegraphed yeah what's up with all the
smash balls
[Music]
oh wait that punch hit him interesting
having felt way like he kind of just
walked into the punch but
oh my gosh I thought he was he was done
oh I've been there before DK don't feel
bad I've been there before
trust me we all have in Smash Brothers
all right here's the bonus game for the
super heavyweight keen K rool classic
mode run-through I was thinking to know
what would be a cool idea first dream is
try to do every every clear every
character in one stream and then I
started looking at like how long it was
taking me on most of these like ten
minutes would be fast for a run-through
honestly 15 minutes would be much more
what you'd expect and then I started
adding it all up and I'm like wait a
second
for all the characters in this game that
would take like 18 hours
24 hour stream folks here we come
I mean that's what it would take
oh come on run dude run run the void the
talk Boyd it's catching us now complete
I wonder if this has been the same
announcer for every Smash Brothers game
here we go with another secret boss I
have no idea who this dude is I'm gonna
look him up right now before I go any
further
what was that gallium GA ll e om look at
this up right now
[Music]
Super Smash Brothers series wait what oh
this dude appeared in brawl I do not
remember this gallium is a boss that
appears in the game Super Smash Brothers
Brawl purple skin monster in a robotic
form first fought by Meta Knight Marth
and Ike after the battle gallium takes a
huge then takes a huge and lands in here
okay what takes a huge what tenir where
Wario was turned into a trophy bla bla
bla bla in boss battle mode gallium is
also only faced once but he alternates
backgrounds between runs of the mode
cool gallium is not the first boss to
fall through the top of a tall circular
building in Super Mario Sunshine the
boss Petey piranha causes the roof of
the windmill which he is sitting on to
crumble and collapse Petey is then
fought inside the windmill much like
gallium is battled after falling into
the ruined Hall I totally forgot about
this guy totally forgot about him how
many we cleared so far um
I should have added that up I will check
after this one I feel like it's at least
probably 10 or 15
oh come on and dodge that
dodge that one bro
whoa calm down don't don't lose your
head it's okay it's okay come on buddy
it's okay it's all right please please
please he's very angry now Oh
he grabbed me that time come on we've
done so well on this one
what okay now he's a tank come on one
more hit one more hit no no no
[Music]
oh dude that was way too close man if I
had been a lighter character I'd have
been gone right there but the heavy
weight the heavyweight King ke rule
prevails as he returns to the stage and
then with a punch to the face destroys
gallium I think it was yeah man I played
a ton of role
[Music]
that's okay brawls been a long time it's
been a very long time since brawl
congratulations I just don't have Diddy
Kong unlocked I just realized that yeah
King K rool and Donkey Kong but we don't
have Diddy Kong it
alright see if he unlocked a new one oh
yeah Chris tally ins been waitin on this
one
Chris tallien has been waitin for this
when people people over the internet
people of twitch the one the only solid
snake now he's probably gonna own us
here and win this fight solid snake
plays just like so different from most
smash characters I think it's what makes
him so interesting come on dude come on
dude I want to land this move
and K rool hits so hard dude he's pretty
quick for a big guy come on I'm trying
to get away from the light please
Oh No Oh No
look who cook Hey Oh and now snake joins
the battle
Otacon we need to stop Metal Gear